Guten Abend! Mein Name ist Aktaqa. Ich bin hier zu unschtern, die Erzitm-Fürzi.
Zu Erzberde, innen, so ira perzön, ein paar Fragen ist eben, da nachkommen wir gelay, so iran beshwerdum.
Wie heißt es hier?
Ich heiße Frank Zimmermann.
Frank?
Mhm.
Und iran nahtname?
Zimmermann.
Könnt ihr jetzt bitte iran nahtname langsam burschtabir?
Ja, Z-I-Doppel-M-E-M und dann MA-Doppel-M dahinter.
Doppel-M.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Zimmermann?
Ich bin 67.
67?
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 2. Mai 57.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin so 1,75.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wieghe 78 kg.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Schmidt.
Mhm.
Mit DT am Ende?
Ja, genau.
Okay. Herr Zimmermann, was führt Sie uns heute?
Ja, also ich hab seit langer Zeit eigentlich immer solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen und
das wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Und ja, das hat mit einmal angefangen und wird aber immer schlechter.
Und also ich hatte das vor, vor viel, 5 Wochen schon mal.
Das ist aber von alleine wieder weggegangen.
Aber jetzt sind die Bauchschmerzen eigentlich so heftig
und werden auch immer schlechter,
dass ich gedacht habe, ich muss unbedingt hierher kommen.
Ich verstehe, Sie haben gesagt,
seit wann genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Dass das jetzt wieder so hochgekommen ist,
das hat vor 2 Wochen angefangen.
Am Anfang nicht schlimm.
Und es war so auf der linken Seite,
oder ist immer noch auf der linken Seite,
und dann habe ich auch eine gute Blinde, es ist nicht okay
auf der anderen Seite,
und kann ja nicht so schlimm sein,
aber es wird überhaupt gar nicht besser.
Mhm.
Ja.
Ich verstehe.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben,
sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend oder stehend?
Eigentlich vielleicht eher dumpf, stehend würde ich nicht sagen, nein.
Mhm, dumpf.
Mhm.
Ja, das kommt drauf an.
Also direkt nach dem Essen habe ich immer das Gefühl,
dass es dann schlechter wird.
Mhm.
Und wenn ich,
also, wenn ich mich schone,
dann ist es nicht so schlimm.
Also, so zwischen 5 und 7 würde ich sagen.
Mhm.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt?
Ja, jetzt.
Mhm.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt im Augenblick vielleicht so bei 5, ja.
Okay, Sie brauchen jetzt keine Schmerzmittel, ich denke.
Nein, ich kann das aushalten, naja, Sie werden ja schon.
Okay.
Und nachdem es dann diese Schmerzen schlimmer geworden ist?
Ja, dann werden sie ganz unangenehm, ja.
Ich verstehe, wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
Sie haben gesagt, dass im linken Seite,
die Strahlen, die Schmerzen, ihr gehen wohin aus
oder nur im Unterbau?
Nee, die strahlen nicht aus, nee, das würde ich nicht sagen.
Mhm.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen außer Essen?
Ist mir nicht so aufgefallen, nein.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das diese Schmerzen lindert?
Ja, also, wenn ich mich hinsetze,
geht es eigentlich immer besser, als wenn ich stehe und rumlaufe, ja.
Mhm.
Wenn Sie hinsetzen, diese Schmerzen, besser wird.
Dann wird es ein bisschen besser, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Also, ich hatte noch so ein Buskupanzäppchen.
Das habe ich genommen, das habe ich mal vor langer Zeit bekommen
und das habe ich mal versucht
und da habe ich auch eine Nacht ganz gut geschlafen
und dann habe ich das nochmal genommen,
als es wieder ganz heftig war,
aber man kann ja nicht ständig irgendwelche Schmerz mitnehmen.
Mhm.
Hab das geholt von?
Ein bisschen hat mir das schon erleichter rumgebracht, ja.
Mhm.
Aber was eben auch unangenehm ist,
ich habe also sehr heftige Blähungen
und ich muss auch eigentlich schon seit langer Zeit
habe ich oft mal Durchfall
und dann habe ich wieder das Gefühl,
dass ich so ziemlich verstopft bin,
dass ich überhaupt nicht auf die Toilette gehen kann.
Sie haben einige Tage Diarrös
und einige Tage Verstufung.
Ja.
Wie viel mal müssen Sie so toll,
wenn Sie Dufalle haben?
Ach, dann kommt so 3-4 Mal am Tag,
kommt dann so weicher Stuhl.
Weiche Stuhl.
Und wie sagt der Stuhl aus?
Haben Sie Blut bemerkt
oder ist das schleimig, weiß ich, reich?
Ja, eher reich, aber Blut
ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Aber dann sind manchmal noch so Nahrungsreste zu erkennen,
dass das eben nicht gut verwertet ist, ne?
Ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen übel oder war Ihnen übel?
Also, so richtig übel ist mir nicht.
Ich habe aber eigentlich nicht viel Appetit,
muss ich sagen.
Ihr Appetit ist schlecht, auch seit 2 Wochen.
Können Sie sagen?
Ja, würde ich sagen, dass du kaut beungefangen hast.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben keine Übelkeit
und haben Sie nicht erbrochen, ich denke?
Nein, erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe manchmal so brennen, da denke ich immer,
oops, kommt da jetzt was, aber
übergeben musste ich mich noch nicht.
Nein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben so brennen und haben Sie völlig gefühlt?
Nein, nicht mal.
Direkt nach dem Essen vielleicht mal.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht das Hauptproblem.
Also ist das unangenehme eher diese Bauchschmerzen.
Das Völlegefühl ist nicht das Schlimmte,
ist nicht auffällig.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und wenn Sie im Bauch drücken, sind die Schmerzen schlimmer?
Ich glaube ja, habe ich noch nicht probiert.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie viel?
Ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen.
Oder fühlen Sie sich viel?
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Aber das kann schon sein.
Ich fühle mich in letzter Zeit häufiger mal so ein bisschen fieberig.
Aber Sie haben nicht gemessen?
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihr Appetit in letzter Woche schlecht ist
und haben Sie Gewicht zugenommen oder abgenommen?
Nee, es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich lege mich aber jetzt auch nicht ständig.
Okay, ist Ihnen nicht aufgefallen?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, so ganz gut schlafen Sie nicht.
Ich muss schon einmal wenigstens in der Nacht auf die Toilette.
Wegen dieser Durchfalle?
Nein, eigentlich mehr wegen der Blase.
Ich verstehe.
Einmal pro Nacht?
Wenigstens ja.
Manchmal auch zweimal.
Haben Sie noch andere Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Schmerzung oder Brennen?
Ja, ich habe hin und wieder mal so Blasenentzündungen.
Aber jetzt in letzter Zeit eigentlich nicht.
Wann war das letzte Mal?
Das ist bestimmt schon drei Jahre her.
Okay.
Und gesagt, dass Sie Durchfalle und Verstopfen wechseln haben?
Mhm.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich irgendwas nicht vertragen kann.
Eigentlich kann ich alles essen und habe keine Beschwerden.
Okay, das ist so gut.
Und wissen Sie, reagieren Sie allergisch gegen einen bestimmten Medikament?
Bestimmtes Medikament?
Also ist mir nicht bekannt, ich wüsste es nicht.
Okay, das ist so gut.
Und jetzt werde ich zu Ihrer folgenden Geschichte ein paar Fragen stellen.
Herr Tischtin, an irgend drei Herr Erkrankungen?
Na ja, was man so in meinem Alter hat.
Ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck
und auch ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Das hat ja fast jeder in meinem Alter ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Erkrankungen?
Ja, das ist schon lange.
Also mit dem Blutdruck, das ist schon 15 Jahre.
Da nehme ich so ein Beta-Blocker ein
und dann morgens und abends.
Welche Beta-Blocker nehmen Sie ein?
Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, wie der heißt.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich ein Beta-Blocker ist.
Aber wie der genau heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Okay, ich werde Ihnen jeden Hausarzt erfüllen.
Und nehmen Sie etwas gegen Blutfette ein?
Nein, also da soll ich ein bisschen vorsichtig essen.
Aber das fällt mir ausgesprochen schwer,
weil ich eigentlich gerne fettige Sachen esse.
Aber das bekommt mir eben auch jetzt
von den Bauchschmerzen gar nicht gut.
Fettige Essen sind leckeres, ja?
Bitte?
Fettige Essen sind leckeres.
Schmeckt gut.
Ja, ja, es schmeckt besser, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Aber nehmen Sie keine Medikamente gegen diese Blutfette ein?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Und leiten Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Also diese Bluthochdruck und?
Nein, nicht ganz.
Eigentlich bisher hatte ich keine Probleme.
Okay, das ist so gut.
Und Sie nehmen nur diese Betablocke ein
und nehmen Sie irgenwann noch andere Medikamente
regernmäßig ein?
Ja, wenn ich mal wirklich ganz schlecht schlafen kann,
so ein bisschen unruhig bin,
dann nehme ich so Baldrian-Tropfen zur Nacht.
Tropfen.
Aber nicht regernmäßig?
Nein, das nehme ich nur hin und wieder mal.
Mhm.
Herzmähmung, raufen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Noch nie.
Ich gratuliere dir.
Hat sie Geld gespart, ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke schon gerne ein Viertel Weinabend.
Viertel Glas Weinabend.
Ja, also ein Viertel Liter, ne?
Also ein großes Glas.
Und bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen,
ob Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen hatten oder haben.
Mit Drogen?
Ich?
Nein, also nein, wirklich nicht.
Okay, diese war eine Frage.
Herzmähmung, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Rentner zum Glück, ja.
Und was haben Sie gemacht, Beruf?
Ja, ich habe im Verkauf gearbeitet in einem Möbelhaus.
Möbelhaus.
Waren Sie selbst?
Ja, ich war selbst.
Waren Sie selbstständig oder?
Nein, nein, nein, ich war da angestellt.
Aber jetzt bin ich eben seit einiger Zeit in Renten.
Und das ist gut, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Und sind Sie verheiratet heute immer mal?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich erwachsen, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Und sind Sie geblieben?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich erwachsen, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
2.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, davon gehe ich doch mal aus, dass Sie gesund sind, ja.
Okay.
Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Mit meiner Frau wollen wir zusammen, genau.
Okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, sie sind ja, die sind ja, die wären ja jetzt sehr, sehr alt.
Mein Vater, der ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, die hatte im Alter dann einen Altersdiabetes.
Könnt ihr Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich kann nicht verstehen.
Ihr war Zucker, ihr war Alterszucker.
Also mein Vater hatte Lungenkrebs und ist da dran gestorben.
Der hatte aber auch heftig geraucht, muss man sagen.
Und meine Mutter, die hatte den so einen Alterszucker.
Okay, wann ist Ihr Vater verstorben?
Der war 82 und meine Mutter war 86, als sie gestorben ist.
Sind also beide auch alt geworden.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Oder waren Sie im Ausland?
Im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also ich bin nur hier innerhalb von Deutschland ein bisschen mal.
Hab ich Freunde besucht, aber sonst nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Herr Zimmermann, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ich denke, ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ich will natürlich wissen, dass man gegen diese Bauchschmerzen machen kann
und woher die kommen und wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Ich habe vergisst, sind Sie gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten
und Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja, Covid-19, ja natürlich.
Und Kinderkrankheiten, das ist schon mächtig, die lange her.
Also da, was jetzt noch so war, Grippeimpfung, das habe ich gemacht.
Und also eigentlich ist mein Arzt da schon sehr hinterher,
dass ich alle Impfungen habe, die man so braucht.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Und Herr Zimmermann, jetzt werde ich Sie untersuchen,
Ihre Baupalperien abtasten
und nehme etwas Blut auf für Laboruntersuchungen
und gegeneinfalls eine Ultraschalluntersuchung notwendig sein kann.
Jetzt würde ich Sie bitte noch einmal kurz im Wartezimmerplatz zu nehmen
und wir rufen Sie in wenigen Minuten auf,
mit der Ultrasuchung anzufangen.
Das ist gut, ja, danke schön.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Sehr schön, ja.
Hat doch jemand Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen?
Ich habe eine.
Ja.
Schwitzen Sie in der Lesterzeit besonders in der Nacht?
Nee, es ist mir nicht auch gefallen.
Schreiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ab und an fahre ich Fahrrad.
So mal am Wochenende, wenn das Wetter schön ist,
aber auch nicht mehr so sportlich wie früher.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Stress oder Angst in der Lesterzeit?
Stress?
Nein, ich bin Rentner, ich habe keinen Stress mehr.
Nein, nein.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie früher einher beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass ich das vor mehreren Wochen mal hatte,
dass es da aber von alleine eigentlich weggegangen ist
und jetzt ist es halt anhaltend.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne einen Patienten vorstellen,
den ich gerade eben in der Notfallnahme gesehen habe.
Haben Sie für mich gut seid?
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben wir denn gesehen?
Herr Frank Zimmermann, 67 Jahre alt,
175 cm groß, 78 kg schwer.
Der Potient stirbt sich bei uns vor,
seit zwei Wochen bis dahinter zu nehmender
abdominalen Schmerzen.
Den Patienten zufolge sein,
die Schmerzen im Linken unterbaut gewesen.
Der Patient schmerzen als dumpf,
mit einer Intensität von 5 bis 7,
von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Der Patient auf püfte hinzu das die Schmerzen,
nachdem Essen schlimmer geworden,
schlimmer zahin,
und leitend berechnet der Patient über
Metaurismus, paradoxer Diöro,
manmal Diöro und manmal Obspacitio.
Wenn der Patient Diöro fahbe,
er muss drei bis vier Mal zu Toilette gehen,
der Stuhl sei breit,
der Patient habe keine Blut bemerkt.
Kein Blut bemerkt.
Er fahbe auf Pyrosis,
und der Patient verneint hematokesie,
nausea, emesis und nachtschweiss.
Der betativen Anamnese zeigte
wie gesagt Diöro und manmal Verstufung,
Nükturi, und der Patient sagte,
er fühle sich fibrig, aber er hat nicht gemessen.
Okay.
Der Patient habe keine Allergie,
der unverträglichkeit.
Er hat die Artillerhütherkologie mit Betablokieren,
morgens und abends behandelt,
aber nahmen nicht erinnerlich.
Ich werde mit seinen Hausarztkontakt bleiben.
Ja, sehr gut.
Er leitet an Hytharkolisterinämie,
keine Medikamente ein,
gegen Hytharkolisterinämie,
der Patient sei nicht raucher,
nie raucher,
3,4 Liter Weinabels
und drogane Konsum wurde verneint.
In der sozialen Anamnese,
der Patient sei rentner,
davor habe als Verkäufer gearbeitet.
Sein Verhaft habe zu diesem Erwachsene kindert.
Und wohne mit seiner Frau.
In der Familienanamnese sei bekannt,
der Vater an einem bronchialen Karstenon verstorben,
82,
und die Mutter habe an Diabetes-Memorialstheap 2 gelitten.
Der Patient verneinte auch Reise
oder im Ausland aufenthalt
aufgrund der Symptomatik.
Habe ich den Verdaft auf
Divertibilitis.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen
kommen chronische Entsündliche Darmerkrankung
und infektiöse Enterocolitis.
Enteritis, ich kann sagen, im Betracht.
Wegen meines Verdafts
werde ich zuerst den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Achten Sie bei der körperlichen Unterrufung besonders?
Ich besonder auf Druckschmerzen
und Abwehrschwörmung.
Danach ich auskultiere auch Bauchabdomen.
Ich kann pathologische Darmgeräusche hören.
Danach legiere ich eine Melodie zu.
Und nehme gleichzeitig Blut ab.
Aus dem Blut möchte ich ein kleines Blutbild
CRPBSG bestimmen lassen.
Gegebenenfalls möchte ich auch für
eine andere Differenzialdiagnose
können.
Ich möchte auch für eine andere
Parameter CRPBSG
CRPBSG
Ich möchte auch für eine andere
kriege person그
CRPBSG
CRPBSM
chronische Entzünder der Merkrankung.
Ach, auch aus, ja genau, sehr gut.
Schließen.
Ja, kommt doch ein Ruhsverfahren in Frage?
Abdomensonographie.
Genau.
Und gegebenenfalls ein City kommt in Bektrat.
Sehr gut, okay.
Ja, wenn dich Ihre Verdacht der Große bestätigt,
das wäre die Therapieoption.
Zuerst werde ich allgemeine Maßnahmen drucken, Flüssigkeit zuvor gaben, Flüssigkeit zu gaben,
Antibiotiktherapie und der Patientenstationäraufnehmer.
Ja, wunderbar.
Sehr gut.
Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was rauskommt bei Ihren Untersuchungen.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über den Herrn Zimmermann.
Und wir können da nochmal zusammen anschauen.
Ja, gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, vollständig.
Und ich, was mir gut gefallen hat,
dass Sie eigentlich auch den so schön systematisch den Patienten abgefragt haben,
aber die Sachen, die er schon erwähnt hat, haben Sie durchaus aufgenommen.
Ja, und haben sich darauf bezogen.
Eine Winzigkeit an Kritik.
Ich konnte sie nicht immer sehr gut verstehen.
Ich glaube, dass, vielleicht weil sie auch leise und vorsichtig sprechen,
aber auch nicht immer super deutlich, dass, also wäre vielleicht noch so ein bisschen
verbesserungswürdig, dass sie ein bisschen präziser und eben auch laut genug sprechen,
dass man sie gut verstehen kann.
Aber es gab in Wirklichkeit keine Verständigungsprobleme zwischen uns.
Ja, ich hätte nachfragen können, wenn irgendwas war, minimal grammatikalische Feinheiten,
wo man sagen kann, ja gut, Werb kommt am zweiten Stelle, meine alte Leier.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich auch immer ein bisschen schammant.
Wenn man hört, eben die Sprache nicht als Muttersprache spricht.
Ein paar Sachen dürfen dadurch sein.
Sie haben sich sehr, sehr gut geschlagen, würde ich sagen.
Und Sie können Ihrer Prüfung, glaube ich, sehr, sehr entspannt entgegensehen.
Ich hoffe auch.
Ich würde Ihnen ganz nette Prüfer und einen sehr spannenden Fall.
Ich hoffe auch. Vielen Dank.
Ja, gerne.
Gut, dann verabschiede ich mich von Ihnen, von Ihnen allen für heute.